Prozess Auftakt gegen sechs mutmaßliche
Unterstützer des Wiener is Killers
quitim fesulay vor fast zwei Jahren im
November 220 hatte der radikal
islamistische Terrorist bei einem
Amoklauf ein regelrechtes Blutbad
angerichtet indem er vier Menschen
erschoss und 23 weitere Verletzte bevor
dann von Beamten der Wiener Polizei
erschossen wurde ja und jetzt stehen
seine Komplizen vor Gericht und eines
der Opfer dieser Terror nach damals
Vanessa P aus Deutschland die 24-Jährige
Münchnerin die hat Kunst studiert in
Wien und nebenbei gekellnert und eben
auch an diesem Abend der ihr letzter
sein sollte
Wien Montagabend 2 November 2020 kurz
vor 20 Uhr es ist der letzte Abend vor
dem zweiten corona-lockdown ein letztes
mal ausgehen durch die Stadt bummeln
etwas trinken gehen mit den Freunden im
beliebten Wiener ausgeviertel Bermuda
Dreieck Herr streger Betrieb der
24-Jährigen Vanessa P aus München kommt
das gerade recht die lebensfrohe junge
Frau ist gerne unter Leuten und freut
sich über jedes Trinkgeld die
Kunststudentin kellnat im angesagten
Restaurant Salzamt finanziert sich so
ihren Traum vom Leben und Studium in
Wien was zu diesem Zeitpunkt noch
niemand ahnt in wenigen Sekunden wird
dieses Idyll ein yes ein blutiges Ende
nehmen
nur einige hundert Meter von Vanessa
entfernt in der Nähe der Jerusalem
stiegen entscheidet sich der 20-Jährige
is-anhänger
q-team ferusal zur blutard
seinen hinterhältigen terrorplan im
Namen des islamischen Staat zu
verwirklichen
er ist schwer bewaffnet neben einer
Machete trägt er eine Pistole und ein
Sturmgewehr samt Munition bei sich
kaltblütig und ohne Vorwarnung zielt er
mit dem Sturmgewehr auf eine Gruppe
Passanten und eröffnet das Feuer der
21-Jährige nedly Pfau der eigentlich mit
seinen Freunden das Ende seines
Grundwehrdienstes beim österreichischen
Bundesheer feiern will hat keine Chance
er ist auf der Stelle tot holt ihm
verusal ist fest entschlossen an diesem
Abend Tod und grauen in der
Donaumetropole zu sehen panisch Rennen
die ersten Passanten davon währenddessen
klappert der Killer die Gassen im
Laufschritt ab sucht neue Opfer und
feuert immer wieder wahllos in die
Menschenmasse
[Musik]
sein blutiger Pfad für dient dabei
direkt in Vanessas Richtung
auch dort im Außenbereich des
Restaurants Salzamt springen die Gäste
auf ergreifen panisch die Flucht dann
wird auch Vanessa zum Opfer von quetim
ferusers Hass
drei Projektile aus seinem Sturmgewehr
treffen die Kunststudentin im Kopf die
mordlos des Attentäters ist zu diesem
Zeitpunkt noch lange nicht erloschen er
zieht weiter durch die Gassen des ersten
Wiener Bezirks zwei weitere Menschen
Gudrun S und Kian l müssen in den
folgenden Minuten noch durch seine Hand
sterben ehe ihn Polizeibeamte endlich
stoppen können Kult ihm für userl wird
an der rupert-stege von den Beamten
gestellt und durch mehrere Schüsse aus
der Dienstwaffe ausgeschaltet insgesamt
kommen an diesen blutigen Novemberabend
samt dem Attentäter fünf Menschen ums
Leben 23 weitere werden zum Teil
lebensgefährlich verletzt
und unser Kollege Jörg völkerling der
begleitet diesen Prozess vor dem Wiener
Landgericht und Jörg du hast einen der
Strafverteidiger bei dir
ja wir stehen jetzt hier unmittelbar vom
großen spurgerichtsaal im Wiener
Landesgericht wo in circa einer halben
Stunde der Prozess gegen die sechs
Angeklagten den Inner Circle den
angeblichen innercircle von kuschtem
fettsulai beginnen soll ihnen wird also
beitragstätterschaft zum Mord
Mitgliedschaften einer terroristischen
Vereinigung vorgeworfen und einer der
Angeklagten ist Ismael B und sein
Verteidiger Doktor Manfred arbacher
steht jetzt neben mir Herr Dr arbacher
was wird ihrem Mandanten konkret im
Zusammenhang mit dem Attentat vom 2
November vorgeworfen meine Mandanten
wird vorgeworfen der Beitrag zum Mord
und der 30-fache Beitrag zum versuchten
Mord sowie der
Mitgliedschaft einer terroristischen
Vereinigung
und welchen Beitrag hat er in ihren
Augen tatsächlich geleistet zu diesem
schrecklichen Geschehen zu diesem
schrecklichen Geschehen was wirklich
schrecklich war hat er gar keinen
Beitrag geleistet und meines Erachtens
kann auch kein Dart Beitrag hier
nachgewiesen werden in welchem
Zusammenhang stand er dann konnten
welchen Kontakt stand er denn mit dem
Attentäter mit dem atemtäter hat immer
ein freundschaftliches Verhältnis
gegeben sie haben sich von Zeit zu Zeit
getroffen aber das kann natürlich nicht
der Beitrag sein zu einem Attentat nur
weil ich mit einem anderen Menschen
freundschaftlich verbunden bin aber es
geht ja in der Anklage sehr viel auch
darum um die Beschaffung von Waffen und
Munition was sagt denn die
Staatsanwaltschaft was jemand dann getan
haben soll die Staatsanwaltschaft wirft
meinen Mandanten vor er wäre dabei
gewesen bei der Beschaffung von der
Waffe und der Waffenhändler selbst sagt
ich kenne diesen gar nicht also ist aus
automatisch war er nicht dabei wenn der
Waffenhändler schon sagt geht nicht kann
man nicht der Staatsanwaltschaft
vorwerfen er war aber trotzdem dabei es
ist ein riesenermittlungserfahren das
zeigt ja auch dass es zwei Jahre
gedauert hat bis es zur Anklage kommt
was droht ihrem Mandanten denn und was
werden sie beantragen also mein Mandant
beginnt sich nicht schuldig drohen in
diesem in diesem Ausmaß wenn das
anklage-konform wovon ich nicht ausgehe
verurteilt werden würde 10 bis 20 Jahre
und Sie werden wahrscheinlich auf
Freispruch plädieren selbstverständlich
es kann nirgends ein Tat Beitrag noch
physisch noch psychisch nachgewiesen
werden selbstverständlich muss ich hier
ganz klar auf Freispruch gehen und das
ist auch der Auftrag
vielen Dank ja das ist der Eindruck der
Verteidiger wird jetzt zu seinem
Mandanten gehen die sechs Angeklagten
werden nicht öffentlich vorgeführt das
wird kein Bild geben von den Angeklagten
und ob sie am Ende des Tages irgendwann
im Februar 2023 wirklich verurteilt
werden könnte 20 Jahren steht in den
Stern zwei Beihilfe wurden schon
verurteilt aber nur wegen Mitgliedschaft
einer terroristischen Vereinigung zu
einer geringen Bewährungsstrafe und
damit zurück zu euch nach Berlin
[Musik]